there is an alarming shortage of
life-saving cancer treatments in the U.S
right now 14 commonly used chemotherapy
drugs are now in short supply so that
means more than 500 000 patients do not
know if they can get the medicine that
they need CBS Evening News anchor and
managing editor Nora O'Donnell spoke to
one of them
Carol noon has an aggressive form of
endometrial cancer it's treatable but
there's no time to waste do you know if
the drugs will be available for the rest
of your treatment no
the night before her second dose of
chemo the 61 year old got a call from
her doctor the hospital ran out of her
treatment
thankfully noon got her dose a week
later so how has this complicated your
recovery process well you know I think
it's an emotional roller coaster it's
very frustrating to know that there's a
standard of care these two generic drugs
and I can't get them what did the doctor
say when you asked what is this delayed
treatment mean for my prognosis
oh my gosh you're frustrated we're just
hoping there's gonna be Treatment
available patients like noon are given
carboplatin and cisplatin generic
medications which are not profitable and
few are made in America since the
pandemic the international supply chain
has struggled making the issue dire
right now FDA inspectors found
widespread problems at a factory in
India that reportedly makes more than
half of the U.S supply of cisplatin I
think we do need answers there are
solutions we just have to think
differently we have to approach this
differently the FDA says it's working to
end the shortage but it can't require a
pharmaceutical company to make a drug or
even make more of a drug for now the
shortage means hundreds of thousands of
sick patients are left in limbo you had
to make some decisions about who we were
going to prioritize during this
difficult time on colleges Dr Kerry
wisinski has never seen a shortage this
serious the question is could people die
because of the shortage I think it all
depends on how long it occurred if we
experienced a prolonged shortage
of chemotherapy then yes I do think
people could die in response the FDA
temporarily began importing a Chinese
chemo drug that doctors say more needs
to be done
someday I'm going to die
I really would rather not die because
these standard generic drugs
weren't available to me and I I can't
imagine my family having that doubt was
it the cancer or was it that there was
not enough chemotherapy and it got
rationed for CBS mornings I'm Nora
O'Donnell in Washington
yeah
it's heavy yeah do not know an answer
you know I have that doubt yeah and with
these shortages a lot of families are
going to have that doubt it shows you
how much we rely on things and take it
for granted until it's possible it's not
there